he's an American business magnate
philanthropist investor and author he's
the founder and CEO of Dell Inc one of
the world's leading sellers of personal
computers Forbes estimates his net worth
to be nineteen point five billion
dollars he's Michael Dell and here are
his top ten rules for success you know
you have to think about the the the
point of impact if you're running a
business with a hundred people the point
of impact for the leader is very
different than if it's a thousand people
or ten thousand hundred thousand and so
that's the frame of reference that I've
always used is to say okay if I'm
leading this organization what are the
things that actually I can do to cause
it to be successful if it's a thousand
people it's very very different than it
is for me today so today I'm a lot more
focused on strategy because that's the
point of impact on 110 thousand person
company on a hundred person company you
know you're sort of doing any job in the
organization you're doing every job in
the organization you know potentially
and that might be okay at that point one
of the things I see in new businesses is
they're often looking for perfection and
I think this is a really big mistake I
think I think you ought to be looking
for experiments and and you know quick
experiments and it's okay to have little
failures and what you want to do is
learn as much as you can very quickly
and try things and you know certainly
when we were a small business you know
we'd go out and try all sorts of things
to find what would work and then you
know we found something work well we'll
do that a hundred more times or a
thousand more times we still to do it
today as a large company when I was 16 I
I got this job working for a newspaper
in Houston and my job was to sell
subscriptions to the paper on the
telephone and I realized two things when
I was doing this I realized that people
that were buying the newspaper generally
had two things in common either they
were moving to a new residence
where they were getting married and it
turns out that you could go find
information about both of those things
in enormous quantities so in the state
that I lived in in Texas when you get it
when you want to get a marriage license
you have to file with the state and it's
public information particularly the
address that you want the license sent
to once it's issued so I hired all my
friends and went to every county in the
surrounding 16 counties in Houston
captured the addresses of all the people
that applied for marriage licenses and
sent them a direct mail offer to offer
them the newspaper for a free trial
menís subscription and you ended up
making a making a fair sum of money for
a teenager you know in our situation
where we were creating a new way of
doing business that was actually part of
our culture as well and as we wanted to
attract people from let's say related
spaces you didn't actually want them to
bring you know the culture of the other
companies we might want some insights
from their experience and that sort of
thing but we had to be very explicit
about what the Dell culture was really
all about what the values are
particularly as we expand around the
world we say know that you know these
aren't necessarily American values these
are the Dell company values and this is
incredibly important and this is the way
we operate our business one of the
things that people do instinctually when
there are tough times is they kind of do
nothing and you know they they don't
they don't
it kind of hunkered down this is frozen
rabbits on the head like yeah you know
it's kind of just just complete stunned
into inaction and I think that's
actually the worst thing to do I think
times when everyone is confused
and kind of stunned present you know the
most enormous opportunity because
nobody's really doing anything so you
know I think this is a time where the
the seeds of really successful new
businesses will be created in fact if
you look in our industry which I'm most
familiar with you know the greatest
companies kind of came out of and were
formed in some of the most difficult
times in the industry when no one was
really looking and everyone thought the
whole thing was going to go south all of
a sudden and whole new breed of
companies you know merge so for example
if you look at you know that when Dell
was formed in the early 1980s 1984 this
was a pretty dark time in the US economy
the personal computer industry had just
gone through a big down cycle and the
prevailing wisdom was that all
electronics would be dominated by the
Japanese yeah you know and and that we
had this big boogeyman called the the
you know Japan Inc and that no one could
compete with Japan Inc and in especially
in something like computers but turned
out to be completely wrong and there you
know his enormous opportunity and huge
waves of productivity were unleashed
with the computer industry you know
flourishing
be willing to experiment and fail you
know a lot of people go into business in
there they're looking to never make any
mistakes that's not the way to succeed
you have to be willing to try things
experiment ask a lot of questions don't
be stuck on any one position and you
know most importantly to listen and look
for breakthroughs and you know ideas
that haven't been haven't been out there
as a business grows
the natural tendency would be to take
fewer risks and to be cautious and to
have contingency plans but in a business
that's changing very quickly or one that
you want to grow you actually need to be
explicit about accepting risk one of the
people who work with me kind of
described it this way they you know I
was sort of encouraging this person hey
you know let's try this when we do this
how about this and some point he kind of
came back and said so what you're
telling me is you want me to try to do
10 things and if I only get eight of
them you know you'll be okay with that
you know if I don't get all you know all
ten versus you know having five things
and doing all five perfectly that's
exactly right you know you know we want
to accept some experiments if you just
dissect the the IT sector look at the
whole thing you've got roughly three
three and a half trillion dollar
industry and there are about ten
companies that have more than 1% of the
3 trillion we have 2% but nobody has
like more than 5 or 6% so it's it's a
it's a actually quite fragmented space
so we work extensively with partners
across the ecosystem and it's a big part
of how we evolve rapidly go quickly
reach new customers gain access to the
latest you know ingredient technologies
whether it's in semiconductors or
software in the ingredients and so the
partnerships and alliances are
incredibly important part of how we grow
if you if you really don't know you know
what what it means to be an entrepreneur
you know maybe art one you know so I
think there's a bit of kind of self
initiative and self-starter you know
that that is incredibly important part
of entrepreneurship me no one can sort
of tell you how to do it you have to
sort of have an instinctual you know
feeling or an idea about about something
and you got to be passionate about it
and I think people that look for great
ideas to make money you know are nearly
as successful as those who say okay what
I really love to do what am i excited
about what I know something about when
we have had failures those have
ultimately resulted in some of the
greatest successes we've ever had you
talk about those particularly when
someone comes to see you and they say
yeah feeling really bad because this
didn't work out okay well let me tell
you about some other things that didn't
work out that we learned a lot from and
you know let's pick ourselves back up
and let's figure out what what we what
we learn from this and how we go apply
that next time you know when you're in
the zone of doing things that no one's
ever done before if you're only
succeeding you're not taking enough risk
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because of one of you
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of Michael
Dell's top ten rules meant the most to
you leave it in the comments we're going
to join in the discussion thank you so
much for watching continue to believe
and you'll see you soon